pak demain il ya près de deux mois mais
c'est une petite fille de 3 ans moore
est égorgé arrêté la semaine dernière en
même temps que trois autres garçons
inculpé de vol
l'assassin présumé a peut-être été
désigné un peu vite dominique verdeilhan
un simulacre de reconstitution qui
débouche sur un coup de théâtre les
enquêteurs ont toujours cru que le
meurtrier présumé de la petite
christelle avait approché seuls les
lieux du drame
mais hier soir fabrice sean v10 kenzo
l'un des trois jeunes gens avec qui
christian jacq et hop il ya plusieurs
voitures le soir du crime a refait les
gestes de celui qu'il affirme être ceux
du meurtrier présumé actuellement
inculpé pour vol fabrice geneveys
arrivant ici pour ce transfert de
justice organisé par le juge lehmann
pourrait être inculpée de non
dénonciation de crime désormais témoins
directs de la faire se lever a déjà eu
maille à partir avec la justice pour des
affaires de moeurs
résidant dans le quartier du drame il
avait déjà été entendue dès le début de
l' enquête après 4 heures
d'investigation dans le quartier belle
croix
le juge d'instruction n'a confirmé
aucune hypothèse
oui tgv pas une déclaration pour
l'instant je vais encore entendre les
témoins jeu pour la sage avait pas de
déclarations ce a confirmé un certain
nombre de choses que non depuis jacques
eto'o est revenu sur ses aveux cet après
midi ses avocats ont vivement protesté
contre cet acte d'instruction alors que
la reconstitution avait été annulée par
le juge
ça fait la démonstration que les aveux
de jacques eto'o comme nous disions dès
le début de la procédure ne sont pas
crédibles
donc c'est donc il marque moins un point
la véritable reconstitution pourrait
avoir lieu la semaine prochaine